[Musica]
bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa vincere ci siano
tanti swing ritorno som l'incredibile
l'incredibile l'incredibile storia di
tony di toni che quest'uovo incredibile
con il suo baffo fantastico che col suo
stile senza precedenti ha cambiato le
sorti dell'umanità è una beffa ancora
l'avete ragazzi è una merda l'ho giocato
la prima voi è stato orribile io vi
giuro ragazzi non ho mai giocato una
roba così
ma il nome l'ho già fatto questo mi fa
era arrivato qua io ma [ __ ]
vogliono farmi di fare livelli si
stranzi di merda ma neanche sotto
tortura proprio che ragazzi veramente
allora io e tony l'ultima volta che ho
fatto sto cazzo di gioco ed era più
bello adesso proprio una merda ma
proprio brutto tredicenne e ragazzi
l'ultima volta che ho fatto sto gioco è
praticamente credo di averlo trovato più
difficile ticket mario cosa impossibile
la vacca [ __ ] zoccolo sapere comunque a
parte gli scherzi non è un casino sto
gioco c'è veramente di più è la merda e
la merda fatta uovo
ma poiché non salta più avanti che mi
distruggo cosa è successo chi cazzo è
questa perché a rete ce la fai andare
alla decisone andare dritto non è ok
minchia 2 ora basta cagata ma si può
essere così stupidi ragazzi impossibile
sto giocose una scienza pure gli
ascensori grazie comunque ragazzi stavo
dicendo prima che credo seriamente che
sta roba sia più difficile di cat mario
perché voi non avete idea devo capire un
attimo come si fa sta parte perché non è
nono sì sì ok no ma potter harry harry
potter non credo che voi capiate
perfettamente la difficoltà di sta roba
perché vede mi vedete saltare così ma vi
assicuro che è impossibile perché sta
merda salta una volta in un modo una
volta in un altro macello si no vedete
che una merda di gioco di merd preferivo
20mila volte giocare a geometri
d'aspetto smesso di giocare già metti
dai single che ho smesso di giocare a
geometri das non lo so neanche io lo
giocherà quelli invece cento le uova
perfetto sentite allora
ok ok vai vai veloce veloce madonna no
ero arrivato alla fine io mi devo
ammazzare cioè una roba insostenibile
lega ma dai ma cribbio
ce la possiamo poi ok ok no no no no no
no no no no
madonna che mi sono cosa ma [ __ ]
timori se la famiglia con lo spray anti
insetti un cazzo fatta morire non ci
riuscirò mai più nella vita rifare
questa cosa bravo pian pian piano
[Musica]
uno stop sino in porta sì sì sì c'è dio
mio stimati rotanti ce l'abbiamo fatta
rega è impossibile ok cos'è sta roba
sì va bene o donna cosa sto facendo di
opzione mozione mi ami ami è salito un
ormone non ho capito cosa è successo in
acciaio l'orgasmo il corpo è bellissimo
è stato uno in estasi dice sto provando
del piacere a giocare sto tipo come il
masochismo no dai mi chiama perché è ma
perché ma dai
ok no no no non è così si può vai dove
cazzo vai dove cazzo ti ammazzo ok no
stavo morendo davvero così c'era da
schiaffi si glutei proprio veramente non
mi sto rifiutando di credere che esista
un gioco del genere piano piano adesso
devi capire un attimo una cosa se tu
perché sono bastardi e che sanno che è
difficile anche se ne mette 12 di
ostacoli ci siamo ragazzi ci siamo ci
sia
no come face bevendo il traguardo
d'acqua sopra c'è il problema è che non
ci arriverò mai nella vita ma va beh
quello è un altro dettaglio perfetto no
perché l'uovo torna indietro perché
perché si chiama pietro e torna indietro
non si chiama tony e hai rotto i
[ __ ] bye bye bye bye bye bye sea
cosa devo fare quale che affermi nati
non fatemi capire prima di morire
oddio cosa ho schivato allora allora
allora allora calmi una donna che ti
stupro la famiglia è stato meraviglioso
ragazzi bellissimo proprio porca [ __ ]
possono fare delle cose no ok ok
sì sì sì ok oddio calmi e successo tutto
in un secondo non ho capito neanche io
come ho fatto ma va bene questo faccio
subito subitissimo proprio senza anche
vuoi capire come a livello nei sub
attico ioni subito ma è così poco
integrale frega na sega niente integrare
la farina non io
che poi questo mi è straziante perché
devi anche aspettare che scenda la mer
c è stata una goduria ogni volta serie
su sti cosi come faccio a fare a meno
che non salti prima e poi vien da ridere
perché volti quella [ __ ] non voglio
incazzarmi questa è l'ultima è l'ultimo
no percoche culo sono caduto giù mi è
andata bene
vai vai vai vai vai vai bravo bravo ok
meno male che c'era una volta che
mettono un ostacolo alla fine voglio
vedere che cazzo succede
potrei lanciare la casa direttamente
proprio una roba centri mil dio mio
ma come fai a cadere sempre allora senti
mi sta ascoltando che non mi sta
prendendo per il culo
mi stai prendendo per il culo di la
verità bravo bravo
no so so ciò ecco bravo pesce st
musichina di merda che va avanti da da
da da da da da niente o non c'è verso
definirci sopra o si si si no ok ok ok
sta venendo da piangere una cosa e
commovente ragazzi incredibile c'è però
un attimo ho creduto di riuscirci subito
solo una volta che luci ci riuscirò
subito senza guardare manco il livello
quella volta non è questo forse sì o
forse sì o forse un pene riesco a fare
neanche il primo ostacolo di merda ora
che in questo ciò che è assurdo perché
tifa perdi la speranza dell'umanità è
nelle uova colpo solo proprio no no
siamo così toni non lo so di mito è cioè
fammi capire fammi capire cosa vuoi fare
la tua vita di merda scrive ragazzi sto
gioco è uno dei pochissimi che va
veramente a qullo ceva solo da solo a
culo dipende come salti problema che non
sa altro che sono un pirla di questo
gioco si compra su steam
ma chi cazzo se l'è comprato sta roba
cioè voglio capire voglio capire io l'ho
preso io l'ho preso ovviamente io sono
un genio e vabbè ma cosa si sapeva ma
cazzo
allora sentite io so già che qua c muoio
perché hanno fatto sto gioco di merda ma
sono tornato ho preferito evitare
l'umiliazione un suicidando mi è stato
divertente dai bravo bravo bravo a
johnny bravo o deve saltare se salto
però dio mio devi saltare toni del cazzo
sì sì beh ragazzi basta così è stato
bello e divertente mi sono rotta
abbastanza le palle per questo livello
si vede più da lontano che cazzo hanno
fumato per farlo è più difficile degli
altri ma questo mi sembra abbastanza
semplice ultime parole ci metto 20 ore a
farlo per occhiali [ __ ] vacca ma dai
cristian deville
niente niente la merda nell'anima no no
no no no devi entrare nel centro al buco
una volta la tua vita bravo bravo toni
no tonino cazzo mi vedo che un giorno me
li riguarderò questito quando solo
vecchio per 80 anni mi riguardano questi
video ma che per un ragazzo che ora ma
come passavo il mio tempo ma guarda un
po ma vaffan
e mica sono ancora di più grosso già
[Musica]
bravo ma [ __ ] però c'è raga io io
devo fare ste cose no dai toni cristo ma
ce l'ha poi ma perché marche problemi
hai nel tuo cervello da uomo di merda
che cazzo si guarda pullman che mi
sfotte con lo schifo alla sentito no no
no no che ti ammazzo ti ammazzo ti
ammazzo ti ammazzo che saltare un cristo
dio sta è sempre quello è sempre quello
o piano velo adesso salò no no mi
incazzo madonna se miraggio gianni
incazzavo in una mania ce l'ho fatta
basta chi cazzo sei tu mi sono messo
tipo 20 ore ti prendi rischia fin faccia
per ora è la faccia
ciao dubbio one to see the ending di
ending you can choose it by yourself poi
sceglie bye bye del never see you again
dove di questo zio di inviare nel culo
anche se non hai il culo nella faccia
bei ragazzi siamo arrivati credo sia
alla fine devo scegliere che cazzo
scelgo se tipo pillola rossa pillola blu
non lo so ragazzi io vado a sinistra
scelgo quella sinistra mi sembra la più
[ __ ]
[Musica]